Film Courage: Before we started with our interview
we were talking about hiring people and people
reacting to the word No.
People reacting to the word Yes.
Can we talk about this and what it means to
you?
Rachel K. Ofori, Producer/Writer: Yes, a little
practice that I have adapted and I still play
around with is when hiring someone or working
with someone or going into any place of partnership
or place where I will have to interact with
someone, I watch the way they respond to No.
Even if I have to kind of strum up an opportunity
where I can tell them No early on or even
if it’s not a No it’s like Alright, give
me a second, whatever it is.
Now in those early stages were you are not
going to come out and say these things.
You have to be very, very, very perceptive
but just see how they react to that and that
is going to usually be a tell-tale sign to
something about their character that you might
have to keep an eye on.
I say I play around with it because I’ve
actually seen this work where I have never
been wrong.
It’s like Okay I saw the way they responded
to No even a year from then they are having
a horrible situation with a co-worker or cast
member or this or that and it comes down to
that one thing where I saw they can’t handle
the No.
Or there is something that stirs up in them
from a No.
And what I’ve seen is you can simplify it
to be in childhood of maybe Mom told them
No too much or maybe Mom told them No not
enough or ever?
Or the teacher was kind of like Well they
are a special kid.
Let’s let them do what they want or whatever
it is where you had freedom to do something
that maybe wasn’t the most like healthy
freedom where you needed some boundaries or
whatever it is.
Some people are then able to mature and seek
out what they didn’t get but most people
aren’t.
Most of us just aren’t that mature.
It just is what it is.
So we are going to fall into a space that
we were prone to from childhood.
Even if you don’t see it in certain moments
you are going to see it when things get bad.
And with film, things are going to get bad
at least one day.
It’s like the moment of truth.
You get to know people so much after you film
and film with people.
Everyone is like like Oh, I love you and whenever
that happened you work with someone for a
year and you love them.
You can work at a plant, I don’t know you
are like What are your kids names?
You don’t know anything about a person,
you don’t have any feelings for the person
but the feelings are high because you’re
very connected, it’s intimate spaces, it’s
long days, it’s things that are uncontrollable
like weather and finance and whatever.
Things that you just can’t control.
So it’s going to stir up people in a more
aggressive way than other vehicles right?
Knowing that you need to know how they respond
to No.
You need to know how they respond to an obstacle
and you need to know how they are going to
interact when they are upset about something
or not happy about something or didn’t like
something.
The way that I find that out in a very limited
way is to early on even before I hire them
to tell then No or Wait or I don’t really
like when you said that.
How do they respond to that?
Scott who I work with he is very much a part
of our company The Audacity but also he directed
the film I last worked on and he is like the
best at I don’t really like that and he
is like Oh, why don’t you like it?
That’s his response, that’s awesome.
It’s not How dare you!
It’s like No it’s okay.
Now let’s talk.
I don’t like that, you don’t like that,
why?
But if someone is like I don’t like when
you said such-and-such or I don’t really
like that idea.
And they get sad, it doesn’t mean don’t
work with them it just means be mindful that
this person may not be able to take those
moments and you are going to have to have
those moments when being creative.
Creatives have to feel confident to talk and
they can’t be shut down by a No.
So there is someone I am working with now,
brilliant!
But the No’s or when the other team is like
What about this?
I don’t really like that idea, what about
this?
You see them pulling back and kind of putting
a wall up and digging into that a little bit
more they didn’t have those opportunities
to kind of like show themselves as a kid and
be validated by showing themselves.
It was more like Stay in your place, no not
right now.
No, stay here.
So when that person starts to feel a little
comfortable and they say what they were thinking
I need the team to be mindful now is not the
time to criticize.
Accept what they just said and then we’re
going to deliver this a little more softer
than I would with Scott.
Scott I don’t like it.
Okay, why?
It’s being mindful of people, being careful
with it but knowing that this is going to
be necessary.
So if it’s necessary for me to tell you
I don’t like your idea let’s find out
how you react to that earlier than like Oh
my gosh, we had a deadline and this person
will literally not write now because now they
are having a mental breakdown because they
don’t like their idea because that can derail
a whole project.
So finding that out early on in a fun little
way, a very easy way that I have adapted to
my own likes is yes, finding out how they
respond to No or Wait or I don’t like it.
Question For The Viewers: Do you pay attention
to the way people around you handle No?